[Musique]
avec vous hélène frade bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline à la une de la
presse les réactions aux débats hier
soir on en parlait à l'instant avec
sandrine entre emmanuel macron et marine
le pen et on commence hélène avec la
presse française un duel sans concession
le télégramme souligne ce matin les vifs
échanges entre les deux candidats
notamment sur la russie sur l'europe du
tac au tac le midi libre jusque emmanuel
macron s'est montré offensif et précis
face à une marine le pen combative et
insistante l'un et l'autre ne cédant
rien à l'adversaire comme lorsque le
président sortant a qualifié la
candidate du rn de climato sceptiques et
que celle ci a rétorqué en le traitant
de klimato hypo christ dans le duel qui
les a opposés emmanuel macron est passé
à l' attaque face une marine face à une
marine le pen en défense mais qui sera
resté pugnacais aurait restauré poster
avec aisance selon le parisien
aujourd'hui en france visiblement
satisfait pauline d'avoir assisté je
cite un vrai débat le président sortant
à l'offensive comme s'il voulait enfin
jeter toutes ses forces dans la
présidentielle écrit le monde en
évoquant une sorte d'inversion des rôles
par rapport à 2007 emmanuel macron qui
pouvait craindre d'être attaqué sans
relâche sur son bilan serait parvenu à
placer sa concurrente sur la défensive
donc au risque je cite de bouyer sa
stratégie de campagne pour apparaître
plus humbles et plus proche des français
mais dans l'ensemble les quotidiens
français hélène à cordes un léger
avantage au candidat macro il macron
domine mais marine le pen tient le choc
dixit le figaro sensible à la sérénité
affichée désormais par marine le pen un
dialogue sans vainqueur par ko mais
avantage au président de 10 le journal à
propos de ce débat de tenues correctes
mais sans garantie de rester dans les
annales sud ouest estime lui aussi que
la candidat du à rennes s'est retrouvée
à plusieurs reprises en difficulté alors
que le président sortant disséquait son
programme toujours pas au niveau singles
libération d'après libé marine le pen
effacé voir fuyante incapable de
s'imposer sur son sujet de prédilection
le pouvoir d'achat aurait manqué de
répondant peiné à garder la tête hors de
l'eau face à un adversaire aux tons
frôlant l'arrogance flirtant entre la
charité la condescendance et qui se
serait livré de son côté un poussif
exercice d'humilité
la presse française reste en partie sur
sa faim le huffington post parle d'une
mauvaise réplique de 2017 d'un débat
moins hostile sur la forme mais dont les
caractéristiques de fonds n'aurait pas
pris une ride le tout donnant à voir une
prestation qui ne devrait pas
bouleverser le rapport de force en
faveur on le sait des manuels macro
comme me semble d'ailleurs en attester
les sondages réalisés après ce débat des
échanges courtois pour ne pas dire
charmant venus parfaire l'entreprise de
normalisation engagé depuis plusieurs
années par marine le pen mediapart
regrette qu emmanuel macron net à aucun
moment employer le terme d'extrême
droite ni dénoncer le racisme et la
xénophobie de son adversaire le tout
donnant lieu à un grand moment de
dépolitisation quand at on pensé à
l'étranger le pen devant la modération
pour réduire l'écart avec macron pour le
quotidien espagnol el país la candidate
d'extrême-droite a su résister rester
dans le jeu en s'enveloppant dans le
drapeau tricolore et en exprimant à
plusieurs reprises son amour pour les
français mais le quotidien espagnol
pauline ironise il arrive que l'amour
fasse un peu peur il arrive aussi que
les promesses d'amour séduisent il
faudra attendre dimanche pour vérifier
si les lecteurs français est désespéré
au point de souscrire à la réplique du
film johnny guitar man moi dis moi que
tu m'aimes sûr de lui macron domine le
pen la tribune de genève évoque deux
candidats faisant assaut de sérieux mais
cette fois tout sourire en évoluant dans
une ambiance très différente et plus
respectueuse qu'il ya cinq ans du film
d'amour du film d'amour haine au film
noir le soir le soir belge a vu lui un
débat à couteaux tirés dominées par le
président sortant et comme beaucoup de
médias étrangers le quotidien souligne
ses attaques contre marine le pen accusé
jeu le site de dépendre du pouvoir us et
de monsieur poutine tandis que le
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung fait état
de la riposte de la candidate sur le
fait que l'europe ne peut pas je les
cite se faire hara kiri avec l'espoir de
faire du mal financièrement à la russie
qui certainement ira vendre son gaz et
son pétrole à d'autres pays le quotidien
allemand note d'ailleurs au passage que
marine le pen a concentré ses premières
attaques contre l'allemagne dont elle
dit ne plus vouloir soutenir les erreurs
idéologique en matière de politique
énergétique
le financial times en ça joue les juges
de paix pas de chaos marine le pen garde
son calme paradoxalement étant donné son
statut c'est emmanuel macron qui a été
le plus agressif maître du détail il a
interrompu sa rivale à plusieurs
reprises au risque de paraître
condescendant marine le pen elle
consciente de son agressivité excessive
en 2017 s'est montré plus modéré
consacrant beaucoup de temps à expliquer
les problèmes de la france et sa
politique plutôt qu'à dénigrer son
adversaire conclusion pauline du
quotidien britannique ce débat aura aidé
emmanuel macron a consolidé son avance
sur sa rivale mais cette course à la
présidentielle reste désagréablement
serré
merci